opioids are drugs that are prescribed to
treat moderately severe or severe pain
examples of these drugs include
hydrocodone
oxycodone
morphine
hydromorphone
and methadone
heroin an illegal drug is also an opioid
in order to understand how opioids work
it's important to know how your body
feels pain
the process begins when something
harmful happens to your body
information about this harm is converted
to a nerve signal
the signal passes along nerves to your
spinal cord and brain
in your brain the signal is perceived as
pain
opioid drugs affect how you feel pain
they attach to structures called opioid
receptors
these receptors are found on cells in
your brain spinal cord and other areas
of your body
opioids act on these receptors to make
you feel less pain
these drugs also have different effects
in other areas
for example opioids act on the reward
pathway in your brain
this causes a release of a chemical
called dopamine that results in a happy
feeling or high
opioids may also cause slower breathing
and they may cause reduced motion of
your intestines resulting in
constipation
for most people when opioids are taken
as prescribed for a short time they are
fairly safe and effective but these
drugs can be taken in ways that weren't
prescribed such as taking too many
taking them to get high or giving them
to someone else
misusing these drugs can raise your risk
of developing drug tolerance dependence
addiction and overdose
tolerance means the drug is less
effective over time
this can happen when opioid receptors
become less sensitive to the effects of
the drug
as a result more of the drug needs to be
taken for you to get pain relief
dependence happens if a person has
symptoms when they stop using the drug
when the drug is removed or withdrawn
you feel sick
this sickness is called withdrawal
opioid withdrawal has flu-like symptoms
that include restlessness and anxiety
muscle aches
inability to sleep
watery eyes and runny nose
nausea and vomiting
stomach cramps and diarrhea
and dilated or widened pupils
opioid addiction is a brain disease
where you have an overwhelming craving
for the drug
you can't stop taking the drug despite
the harm it may cause you
addiction is not the same as dependence
you can be tolerant of a drug or
dependent on a drug without being
addicted to it
finally opioid overdose is a condition
where taking too much of the drug can
cause life-threatening symptoms or even
death
the symptoms of opioid overdose can
include confusion feeling very sleepy or
not alert
nausea and vomiting constricted or small
pupils
unconsciousness
slow or stopped breathing and death
according to the centers for disease
control over 100 americans die each day
from opioid overdoses
if you have questions about opioids or
if you or someone close to you needs
help for an opioid use disorder
talk to your health care provider
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or nmall
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you